[MUSIC PLAYING]
QUAN TO: So I want to thank
you guys for all coming today.
I appreciate you guys taking the
time to come out and see this.
And today, we're
actually going to talk
about the Private Catalog.
So this is actually the
first time we're actually
talking about this publicly.
We just launched
our alpha last week.
And so I want to talk to
you about what we've built
and why this might be
beneficial for your enterprise.
So before we start, I actually
want to take a quick survey.
How many of you here actually
consider yourselves a cloud
IT admin?
Cool.
All right, we've got a few.
How about developers?
A few here.
Architects?
One, two, three, four.
OK, cool.
All right.
So this talk is actually going
to touch on most of that.
For the rest of you
here, hopefully we'll
have something for
you guys, as well.
But basically, we'll
talk about what we're
doing with the Private Catalog.
So I'm going to define the
Private Catalog the way
we think it should be.
It's to enable service
producers and cloud
admins to control
distribution of solutions.
We want to ensure internal
compliance and governance.
And we want solutions
to be discoverable
within your enterprise-- and,
of course, easily deployable.
So the words control,
compliance, governance,
discoverable--
so those are the key things
that I want you to take away
from this session today.
And those are the
pillars that we
used in order to actually
build the Private Catalog.
So I'm going to do things
a little different today.
Instead of giving you a bunch
of slides of how great this is
and all the features and
functionality and everything,
I want to tell you a
little bit of a story.
We're going to walk
through it and show you
how a fictional
enterprise might actually
leverage the Private Catalog.
So there's a company
called ACME Game Studio.
So ACME has about 500 people.
They've been around
for a few years.
They've got a huge market
share on game development
on mobile devices.
So they develop for iOS.
They develop for Android,
Windows Phone, Nintendo
devices--
anything you can think of.
So these guys basically
have an IT environment
where they develop virtual
machines for their dev and test
environments.
So the way it works
is, a developer at ACME
will go find the
right VM that they
need to develop their product
or their feature or their bug
fixes.
They'll deploy that.
That VM actually contains
all the SDK tools,
their build tools, integrations
with their build lab--
everything's there.
So they can go ahead, fix
it, then deploy the test VM.
The test VM's got to contain
all the emulators that they
need in order to
actually test their bug
fixes or their features.
And if everything
looks good, they'll
go ahead and check it in and
then shut down the machines.
That way, they don't
spend a lot of money.
They don't leave machines
idle all the time.
And that's the environment
that they are actually using.
So I want to introduce
Andy, who is a cloud admin.
So Andy's the guy at
ACME that actually
manages those 20
virtual machines
within their enterprise.
So he's the one
that updates them.
He notifies all the developers
when everything is changed.
And so there's new tools
coming out all the time.
There's patches coming
out all the time.
So he's updating constantly--
like, every few weeks,
he's changing things.
And originally, he was
sending emails to everyone
when things changed.
And so emails get lost.
He sends a lot emails.
As you guys know, developers
then end up ignoring those.
And then they get lost, and no
one knows what's going on next.
So he handles a lot
of support tickets.
He gets 30 to 40 a week.
And most of these
tickets are like,
"Where's the latest image?"
Just, "I want to get
my job done," just,
"Where's my latest image?"
So he decided he's
going to create a wiki.
So anytime he made the
update, he updates the wiki.
He tells everyone,
go to the wiki.
The wiki's going to have a link
to the latest and greatest.
Everyone was happy.
Then he went on vacation.
The guys taking over
forgot to update the wiki.
People started
deploying older images,
and then they ran into the
same problems over and over.
So here's Darryl.
Darryl's a developer at ACME.
He's been there for
a couple of years.
He loves the company.
He loves the culture.
He just hates the tools.
He has no idea
where things are at.
He just wants to deploy
the latest and greatest.
He wants to be in
compliance with whatever
the company's set.
All the rules, all
the governance stuff--
he just doesn't want
all that friction.
He just wants to
get his job done.
And so whenever he
needs a new image,
he has no idea where to get it.
There's a bunch of
emails floating around.
There was a wiki.
There's no wiki anymore.
He doesn't know what's going on.
He has to ask around, ask
people, ask coworkers,
phone a friend.
He just doesn't know
what he needs to do.
So Darryl basically
just doesn't care.
He just launches his VMs,
goes, fixes his bugs,
and then just keeps it running.
So he's constantly
causing a lot of money
to be wasted while
his VMs are actually
just being left around.
And because the tools
keep going updated a lot,
anytime he makes a
change, he checks it
in-- he's making a
huge risk that he's
going to break the build.
So when he does break
the build, then he'll
go find the right VM, go code
for his change, go test it,
and then check that in,
causing a couple of delays
for everyone else, blocking
everyone in the pipe.
So not really great.
So does this sound
familiar to you guys?
Do you guys handle this?
I see a lot of nodding heads.
Good.
So let's go try to
help Andy fix this.
So I'm going to actually
do a demo of the live bits.
I mentioned that we actually
shipped the alpha last week.
So I'll be running
the real thing
and showing you guys how
Andy's going to actually fix
some of these problems.
Can you guys switch over?
Cool.
All right.
So I'm actually logged
in as the ADME acmin--
sorry, the ACME admin.
And to get to the Private
Catalog, on the left nav
was the Private Catalog.
So what you're seeing here is
what we call the zero state.
So you've got nothing in here.
This is the Private Catalog.
There's nothing for
you to see, because we
haven't added anything.
As an admin, I actually
have a button here
that says Go to Catalog
Manager-- so that's on the left
here, Manage Solutions.
So I'm actually now
in the Admin Console
for the Private Catalog.
So the first thing I want to
do is actually go and create
a catalog.
So what is a catalog?
A catalog is really just a
grouping of the solutions
that you want to make
available to your end users.
So creating a catalog
is actually really easy.
Just click on Create Catalog.
And let's just call
this Dev Tools--
tools for developers.
So the name is
actually important,
because that's actually
what we're going
to show to your end users.
And then the description is
just for the admin itself.
So I'm actually creating
a catalog right now.
It's taking a few
seconds, because this is
real code working in the back.
And the visibility of
catalogs is actually
dependent on a few things.
I'm actually going
to back up, because I
want to show you how
multiple catalogs interact
with each other.
So let me actually create
one more catalog here.
I'll just call this Test Tools.
So as this is being created,
I mentioned visibility
depends on a few things.
One is, when you
create a catalog,
after you're ready to make
it visible to your end users,
you want to share it somewhere
in the GCP hierarchy.
And that will be at the org
level, the folder level,
or the project level.
Then you need to grant
access to your users
to that org, folder, or project.
And that user will also need
an IAM role to view catalogs.
So those things all need to
be in effect before the end
users can see it.
So as the admin, you control
where it's getting displayed
and then who has access to it.
So I've created my two catalogs.
So there's a Dev Tools
and a Test Tools.
And going in there,
I can add a solution.
So we're in alpha.
We still have a long ways to go.
But for our alpha, we have two
solution types that we support.
The first is a link solution.
And a link solution is
really just a reference link
to anything.
It could be a link to
a Terraform script.
It could be a link
to documentation.
It could be a link to
a GitHub repository.
So it's really whatever
you feel should
be available to your end users.
You can add that.
The other one is a
Deployment Manager solution.
So for those that don't know
what Deployment Manager is,
Deployment Manager is
basically a way for you
to set up a directive to
deploy GCP first-party content.
And so you can use
Deployment Manager
to deploy VMs,
containers, deploy
a VM with an auto-scaling
group and a load balancer--
pretty much anything
that GCP can support.
So it's in my Dev Tools.
Let me go ahead and
create a product.
So this is going to be
my Android Dev Tools--
so Android development
tools with SDK--
I think they're at 29.
I'm not sure where they're at.
The tag line is the
short description
that your end user's going to
see in the little tile view.
So I'll just call this
Android Dev Tools.
So I can go ahead and browse.
Give me an icon here.
Here's one I've picked out.
Support information
for your end users--
so if they ran into problems,
don't know who to contact.
So I'll just say
contact admin@ACME.com.
ACME admin for the creator.
So the Deployment
Manager template--
this is where you would go
ahead and point to the template.
So let me show you what one
of these templates look like.
So one I created,
which has a zip file.
I'm going to open it up.
And so on of the things I
mentioned earlier was control.
So how are you actually
going to control
what and where your
users are going
to deploy these solutions to?
So let me zoom in here.
And so in my example
here, I'm going
to show you how to actually
control what machine type
and what region the user
is going to deploy to.
And so here, we have zone--
the property zone.
And we've got machine type here.
So this is actually
going to set up
a parameter as part of
the deployment experience
so that when the end
user's deploying this
to their Private
Catalog, they'll actually
be able to select from a
list that you, as the admin,
curated, that you want
them to deploy to.
And the way that works
is that there's a schema
file that you would include
with your Deployment Manager
template.
I'm going to bring this up.
And so I mentioned how there
was machine type and zone.
So you'd define it
here, where you'd
have your different
machine types
and then the zones available.
So to show that this is
all real, let's go ahead
and actually just limit these
users to deploy to N1 standards
and deploy to just one region.
Let's say US Central.
So let me save
this and close it.
And I'm going to zip this
up, and then we'll actually
use this as part of the demo.
One gotcha is, you do need to
name your Deployment Manager
templates the same name as
the template file itself.
We've got our DM
friends down here.
They can explain why later.
I'm not sure why.
But that's just a limitation
we have right now.
So I'm going to go ahead and
browse to that file I added.
And here's the zip file.
And I'm going to add.
So that's pretty much it.
That's how you add a solution
to the Private Catalog.
So to make it look a
little better later,
I'm going to go ahead and add
an iOS Dev Tools, as well.
And that way, at least
it will look pretty cool
when we actually have multiple
products in the catalog.
So here's the iOS tools.
I can't use the other logos.
And I've got another
zip file for iOS.
Cool.
So now I've added two
solutions to one catalog
for my Private Catalog.
And now, I'm going to
go to my test catalog.
And let me add a link solution.
So let's just call this
the Android Developer
Documentation.
So Android Dev Docs.
So I'm going to give
this an icon, here.
Same support information,
contacts, admin--
admin.
So here, for your reference
links, you just put in a URL
to anything.
So in this case,
developer.android.com.
So now, I've added a link
solution to my test tools.
So I have three solutions total.
So I mentioned
earlier, visibility
actually requires a few things.
So it's sharing the catalog
somewhere in the GCP hierarchy,
granting permissions
to that user
to that location
in the hierarchy,
and making sure that end user
has the catalog viewer IAM
role.
So let me go ahead and share
this catalog to a project
that I created earlier.
And I'm going to share the
second catalog to, also,
a project in my hierarchy.
Now I'm going to
go to the end user
view of the Private Catalog.
So I'm at the org level, which
is why you don't see anything
right now.
So if I go to the project
level of where I just
shared those solutions
to, you can actually
see the three
solutions I created.
So now, let's go
into one of these.
Actually, no.
Before I go there, you can see
the different catalog names
that I entered earlier.
So I mentioned
that was important,
because this is what your
end user's going to see.
So I can filter by the catalogs.
And you can see the
two Deployment Manager
templates I added there.
I can filter by the
different types.
So here's the Deployment
Manager templates.
We've got the
reference link itself.
I can also search
against the description,
against the product name.
This will bring down-- it
will show me what's there.
And then if I go
into one of these,
this is the detail page
for the content I created.
So you're probably
wondering-- this
looks a lot like the
Google Cloud Marketplace.
And it does, because we actually
are reusing the same components
on the front end
and the back end.
In fact, we're
actually the same team
that built the
marketplace that's
building the Private Catalog.
So in here, I want
to go to a link.
If I click here, that will just
take me to the reference link.
So if you're not deploying a
Deployment Manager template
and you want to use this, again,
you can point to documentation,
point to GitHub repository,
point to Terraform scripts--
whatever you'd like.
And then on the tool side, I
can go ahead and actually launch
this VM that I
actually added earlier.
So the first thing I need to do
is, here's my [INAUDIBLE] test.
So here's the parameter.
So you saw me, earlier,
actually delete
those items inside the zip file.
And so now, as an
end user, imagine
that they're coming in here.
I want to deploy this
VM, and I can only
choose these machine
types and these zones.
So your end users
can't go deploy
in the biggest possible,
beefiest machine
and waste a ton of
resources and money.
And they can't deploy
two different regions,
because you're limiting
to what they can do here.
So I just go ahead and choose
the machine type and zone,
hit Deploy.
This goes through the regular
Deployment Manager experience.
And then this will just go
ahead and deploy and go through.
So I'm going to go back to
the slides, if you guys can
help me switch back.
All right.
Cool.
So I just showed you how
easy it was to actually
go create a catalog,
go add content to it,
and then make it
visible to your users.
So basically, from a
discoverability perspective,
it's really easy for people
to know what's available,
because they just go to
this end user console.
For our governance and
compliance, you as the admin
make sure that your
users are deploying
the latest and greatest that
you're making available.
And then from a
control perspective,
you saw how I basically
put in guardrails.
So those end users can't go
ahead and deploy willy-nilly
on any machine types or
any regions that they want.
And because it's
all parametrized
and it's through
Deployment Manager,
you could change
those parameters
to wherever you want.
You can set up different
ranges for auto-scaling groups,
different parameters.
You can set up
different RAM types
that you want them
to deploy, as well.
So all that configuration
and control is up to you
as the admin.
Best of all, this
is going to be free.
So we're not going to
charge you for this.
This is going to come out.
You can just use this
in your enterprise.
We want you to deploy
more GCP solutions,
but this is actually
going to be free.
So let's dig a little
bit into the four
pillars I mentioned earlier.
So discoverability-- so when you
have someone new to your team--
someone that just
transferred over,
someone new that you hired--
I think it's great to just
say, go here and deploy all
the approved solutions for you.
This is a single tool.
So I've talked to
several customers
in the last few months,
as we were building this.
And I asked them explicitly,
what do you guys use today?
How do people discover
stuff in your enterprise?
And I've heard everything
from wikis, emails,
notepad documents, spreadsheets,
word docs-- it's all over.
So we're getting
rid of all that.
Here's a single place.
I showed the
searching, filtering--
so you can filter by
the solution type,
by the different catalogs.
And then as an end
user, if you have access
to multiple catalogs,
you'll see a union
of all that information--
which I kind of showed earlier,
where you had two catalogs,
and you actually saw everything
that I shared to that project.
So for internal
compliance and governance,
this is all about
your end users.
So your end users want to know
that they're always deploying
the latest and greatest.
They don't want
to think about it.
They don't want that friction.
They want to be confident
they're deploying the latest,
best solutions that you, as
the IT admin, has put in there.
So they want to know that
they've deployed all the latest
security patches.
Security's a big
thing right now.
There's new patches coming on.
There's vulnerabilities
happening all the time.
Images get updated.
They don't have to worry about
that, because you're putting up
the latest and greatest.
Every company has
its own policies.
Again, they want to make sure
that wherever they deployed,
someone has approved,
so they don't
have to even think about it.
And then for
compliance, if you have
a lot of VMs, a
lot of solutions,
and you need to
update them, we have
APIs to allow you to
actually do bulk updates.
So control-- so sharing of the
catalogs at the GCP hierarchy,
at the organization,
folder, or project level.
So visibility depends
on that end user
having access to that hierarchy
and having the IAM role.
So talking about IAM roles, we
have an IAM role for admins,
as well.
So you don't have a bottleneck.
You don't just have one person.
So you can have multiple admins
manage and curate your catalog
and the products themselves.
So I mentioned earlier
the guardrails.
So you can put up
guardrails to make
sure people aren't
deploying machines
that they shouldn't
be deploying to,
that they're actually
deploying to the regions
that you're limiting them to.
You can add RAM, scaling
groups-- anything you want.
And then only the admins can add
content to the Private Catalog.
So admins are controlling
what actually gets to be there
and what your end
users are going to see.
So this highlights
that DM template again.
It's kind of hard to see on
that little notepad document I
had earlier.
But what I've highlighted
here is basically
how you would actually go
ahead and define the guardrails
within your Deployment
Manager template.
And then inside the
schema file, this
is where you would enumerate
the different combinations
of things that the users
would be able to get to.
So let's talk a little
bit about the APIs.
So we built the APIs first.
We build it with
the product itself.
It wasn't an afterthought.
And we do have admin APIs
for all the CRUD operations--
so creation, update, deletion.
And so this is great for bulk
updating of your content.
We have end user APIs as well.
And so this is
allowing you to query
for what your user
actually has access to.
And so this will be useful for
enterprises that currently,
potentially, have their
own solution right now
and want to include
cloud software.
Or let's say you had
ServiceNow in your enterprise,
and you don't get rid of that.
But you do want
include GCP content.
So you could use
the end user APIs
to check what the logged-in user
has access to and then query
for that.
And then for deployment, you can
leverage the Deployment Manager
APIs, which are
currently public.
And these slides will
be available later.
So there's a link to the
Deployment Manager APIs.
So end user query APIs--
we've got catalogs, where you
can list and get catalogs.
You can do products.
You can do versions.
On the admin side,
we've got catalogs.
So you can go
create the catalogs,
you can update catalogs,
you can delete catalogs.
I think we have an
un-delete catalog, as well,
if you screw up.
So we have identities
so you can check
what the identity of the user is
and what roles that they have.
We have association.
This is what I called
sharing, earlier.
So this is APIs to share
the catalog with some part
of the GCP hierarchy.
So then, of course, the
products and version
APIs, as well, for
your solutions.
So I want to give you an example
of how you can use these APIs.
So let's say you actually
had a CI/CD solution
to build these VMs.
And so it exists today.
You've got, maybe,
a GitHub repository.
You've got some scripts.
And so any time someone
actually makes an update,
there's a process
that gets kicked off
that basically
generates a new VM,
deploys those scripts onto
the VM, runs those scripts.
And you can integrate with that
process that you currently have
and call the Private
Catalog APIs, which
then will allow
you to then update
that solution inside
your Private Catalog,
for your end users.
That way, you've got
that full life cycle.
Everything works.
It's this full solution.
And your users, again, don't
have to care about that.
They're always going
to be deploying
the latest and greatest.
So we launched our
alpha last week.
This was actually a good sprint.
We've actually worked on it
for only about six months.
So what do we have today?
So we have that UX experience
that you saw for the end user
and for the admin.
So we have our APIs
to where you can
do CRUD operations on the
products and on the catalog.
We've got APIs for end
users, for any integrations
that you may want into
your own homegrown solution
or something like a ServiceNow
or anything out there.
We allow you to create
multiple catalogs.
So it's up to you on
how you want to define
how your catalogs should work.
It could be a catalog
just for developers.
for a certain platform.
It could be a catalog just
for your legal department--
whatever you want.
But you can create as
many catalogs as you want.
There's no limits there.
So you can have IAM roles
to allow other admins
to go and manage those
catalogs and those solutions.
So we support two
content types today.
So there's the reference
links and Deployment Manager
templates.
And so our goal is, of course,
to continue adding to this
and add more solution types.
So there is a single point
of entry for your admins
and your end users.
And basically, the
IAM permissions
will gate whether they have
access to the Admin Console
or not.
So that simplifies, so everyone
just goes to a single place.
So we integrate the DM
experience, which looks exactly
like the Cloud Launcher.
So you have the same flows.
So anyone familiar with
the Cloud Marketplace?
We actually just
changed the name.
So anyone familiar with
the GCP Cloud Marketplace
can just follow that same path.
And then if you have
any org policies set
within your organization and
if you use the DM constraints,
we're going to respect all that.
We're not going to
override anything.
So all that works well
within the GCP environment.
So I want to give you guys
an opportunity to influence
our roadmap.
So we have just
shipped an alpha.
And so we have a lot of ideas
on what we want to do next
and how we want to make
this bigger and better.
But we want to make
it so that it's
something that's enticing to
you, that you want to use,
and that you're going to
deploy in your enterprise.
And so one way you can help
us and influence our roadmap
is to actually go
take the survey.
Actually, can you just
flip to the next--
to my machine?
All right.
So we've got a
MaxDiff survey here
that I'd love for
you guys to take.
And it's 10 questions.
It's going to list
a bunch of features
that we're thinking of adding.
And so all you need
to do is like, this
is the least important,
this is the most important
on each one of these.
It'll take about
five, 10 minutes.
But the data you're
going to give us
is going to be really
valuable, because then it'll
help us understand what are
the things that you do need
in your enterprise to make this
really useful and valuable.
So it would be a great
partnership for you
to just help take this survey.
All right, can you
guys flip back?
Cool.
All right, so
g.co/cloud/privatecatalogsurvey.
All right?
So we're in alpha.
It's not publicly available,
but it is available.
So we want you
guys to try it out.
So cloud.google.com
/privatecatalog/signup.
So it's a really simple form--
give me your name, email,
company title, and then
we'll get you whitelisted so
that you can try it out.
We've got a ton of
documentation we already wrote.
So you walk through the scenario
that I presented earlier.
We even documented it, as well.
So you can follow the same
steps and things that I've done.
We've got a getting started
guide, a quick starter guide,
as well.
So try it out.
Go to the cloud.google.com
/privatecatalog/signup.
And then send us information.
We'll get you hooked up.
And then if you guys
have any feedback,
private catalog
feedback@google.com.
So let us know if there are any
features you think are missing,
if you have any comments--
things like that.
I'm on this alias.
A bunch of the team
is on it, as well.
This is a great way for you to
get in direct contact with us.
And again, we want to build
this thing so that you guys can
use it, right?
We're building this for you, to
help you with your enterprise.
And so we'd love
to partner with you
guys to make sure
that we're building
a great piece of
software that you
do want to leverage and use.
So with that, I am done.
[APPLAUSE]
Oh, thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]